i want to introduce real quick what the
one the love language yeah do that one
yeah why you'd die over here
so so the uh the five love languages
was a book put out by a guy named gary
chapman he was a
counselor okay um 1992
so quite some time ago and he
he had a theory that each person had a
well okay i'm not gonna call it a theory
he had an idea
all right that each person had a primary
and a secondary love language
those languages or those those those
love languages okay that quote it all
right
were words of affirmation quality time
receiving gifts
acts of service and physical touch and
so he had an idea that people express
love one of these five ways and that the
key to relationship success was that you
have to match
you know have a have a partner match and
understand
their love language their primary and
their secondary now
here's the thing uh there's no evidence
to support this nobody challenged it
there's no there's no
until 2017 nobody put this to
a clinical test at all like or any kind
of research
they just assumed that sounds like a
great idea
and the reason of course it sounds like
a great idea to get right down to it is
because
it sets up a transactional sex dynamic
which is what most people in the blue
pill world will call it
are useful before we dive too deep into
your uh
sermon um let's take the quiz
so we can get some frame around what it
is that this is all about
i've plopped it up here so we've got
couples quiz
they actually have a children's quiz
teens quiz so i guess singles quiz is
the one that i'll take is it's most
relevant uh let's get started i am a
male
45 plus uh or in the united states let's
say
i have not read the damn book it is more
meaningful to me
when someone i love sends me a loving
note text
email for no special reason i hug
someone i love
um you know what's more meaningful to me
when i get one of those text messages
with like a naughty picture
in the morning or at a time when i'm
busy doing something that's important
with like some
caption that says i hope it's not a bad
time but it's like the dirtiest picture
that's more meaningful to me than both
of these but which one of these two
would be the closest i'm going to say
somebody sends me
a loving note text all right we'll go
with that oh crap that
we only hit one and that was three
percent this might take a few minutes
but bear with us because
there's we're doing research here for
you guys research
live live research this is live just
just for you tonight and i promise we
will entertain you
it is more meaningful to me when i can
spend alone time with someone i love
just
us someone i love does something
practical to help me out
see now we're getting into transactions
here right yes exactly
so it's it's more meaningful if there's
some transactional stuff going on okay
that would be interesting right because
if we're talking about the alpha seed
side of the equation
this is what the women are going to pick
if we're talking about the beta need
this is what they're going to pick right
absolutely and that's what the they they
ignore the fact
that's what it misses completely is that
they're completely circumstantial
the guy that the losers they've settled
with they want
they want her uh that guy to do
something stuff for her right
whereas the guy that they were you know
banging in college that they had
genuine desire for well they want to
spend time alone with that guy
so their love language will ironically
change
based on desire which we'll get to bingo
all right so let's go all lovey-dovey
we'll go with the i just love one okay
so
it's more meaningful to me when someone
i love gives me a little gift as a token
of our love
of concern for each other or i get to
spend uninterrupted leisure time with
those
i love that one i don't know i
i kind of like getting woken up in the
morning with a bj where's where's that
option
yeah that option there i think it's
number two maybe okay well i don't know
let's just quickly keep going through oh
so
it's a sequence of choose your own
adventure it's more meaningful if than
that sort of thing right
yeah someone i love does something
unexpected for me to help me with a
project
i can share an innocent touch with
someone i love
yeah i don't know so steve steve from
accounting gets the innocent touch in
the uh
in the in the broom closet at the office
right or as you know
some guy that she's just kind of you
know using for
uh the project or something
that that he wants to date her but she's
not that interested yeah he's
yeah that's the first one this is a this
is a serious flaw with this quiz system
yeah it's it's interesting in concept
and
we talked about this um not we like as
in you and i but
we as in a group that i was with around
um at a entrepreneur's retreat like we
actually talked about this in
depth and there was a lot of emphasis
put on the reality of this having a
better impact on
your relationships this is just i don't
know okay
let's keep going and see what else it
has uh it's more meaningful again so
each question is always the same
uh someone i love puts their arm around
me in public someone i love surprises me
with again where's the wake me up in the
morning with a bj option
i don't yeah okay so let's go with
surprises because that's closer
whoever made this quiz up doesn't even
know clearly
someone it's more meaningful when
somebody makes me a sandwich or
yeah it gives me some skull
stop being silly on youtube okay um i'm
around somebody i love even if we're not
doing anything i can be comfortable
holding my hands high fiving or putting
my armor
okay i don't know i receive a gift
hey you guys outside
i can do awkward they love me i receive
a gift
so so it's about transactions over here
receiving gifts
or receiving attention is what this
one's saying yeah i sit close to
somebody i love i am complimented by
somebody i love for no apparent reason
i get the chance to just hang out with
somebody i love so attention
i unexpectedly get small gifts from
someone i love so stuff
attention stuff alpha seed beta need
this is basically what it's starting to
boil down to
i hear someone i love tell me i'm proud
of you someone i love helps me with a
task
do we need to finish this i don't think
so like you guys get the idea like do we
we don't need to keep going right let's
let's stop this okay
and here's where okay so that's a big
like criticism
i have many criticisms of it but here's
one big one
is what a big fat waste of time like if
we were to try to go through that entire
quiz
okay we would spend a good portion of
this show
about an hour show going through this
quiz
and maybe you know might take somebody
an hour to get through this
here's the problem though these are
people that are struggling in their
relationships
oftentimes by the time they reach and
pick up this book
it's because things have gone wrong and
they don't have time to waste
and they're putting time and energy into
what's amounts to very flawed uh concept
and that's really designed to set men up
for failure well men and women both up
for failure
um i put a uh in a little private chat
there because i don't
have i don't have myself set up to
really uh just throw it in the chat uh
right now i don't know why because but
but if you wanna that's that's a um
that's just a link to one one of the
studies the only study
really uh done um in 2017
finally 25 years after the inception of
the book
and understand that you referenced in
your video
uh yeah and so and so yeah that study
it was done in 2017 they took 68 couples
and um or 67 couples rather and they
they assess them based on their love
language preference
self-regulation and relationship
satisfaction
um there were you know the results you
know basically said
that there was no correlation between
relationship satisfaction and their love
language
none whatsoever none whatsoever and
it boils us down to really what you know
the the real thing if you take nothing
else away
is that the real dynamic has nothing to
do with someone's love language
it has to do with it or what we should
rather
appropriately call them we're really
being scientific here
preferences right i might have a
preference for this or that or the other
but it doesn't matter if the person
genuinely desires you
and that's the whole point we talk about
this all the time when she has genuine
burning desire for you
and sees you as her best and is para
bonded to you
you could do any one of these things
mentioned
or none of them at all and she'll be
happy with you and that's the whole
thing
she actually wants you know what women
want they want all of these things
plus more things they want it all but
they want it from a guy
that they really desire and that they
really want but
it becomes yeah it just gets it they it
becomes a negotiation with guys they've
settled with
that they don't truly desire that's the
dynamic
and by attacking it the problem in this
manner
it you're setting it up for a
transactional relationship and this is
why
a lot of marriage counseling fails there
are marriage counselors that hand off
this book
and say yeah you guys get your love
languages in order
yeah really yeah because this guy was a
counselor and a clinician and
and i believe a doctor who came up with
it yeah no research behind it
until 2017 you know 25 years later they
got he has so many versions of this book
out
you know for kids five level labels just
for languages for kids
for military i mean it's yeah couples
like we saw it on the homepage when i
landed on
yeah yeah and it's like but who cares i
don't know
really who cares because you're
interested in somebody you're gonna
figure out what their preferences are
you don't need a book to tell you that
you know what i mean it's like i don't
need a book if i'm really into my chick
i don't need a book to tell me
how to pay attention to her and figure
out what her preferences are
you know what i mean but what matters is
does she desire me
otherwise because she doesn't it doesn't
matter really what i do
you know it ends up being a negotiation
or a bargain and that
does accomplish something though like
what it ends up doing is it
is it deals with crappy relationships in
such a way where it builds a better beta
like she has a guy that she's not happy
with and she wants him to be better he's
still going to be a
better male that she's not going to be
that turned on by but he'll be
he'll be supplicating her whims and
needs that much better
you